[Musique]
bienvenue dans le grand studio du figaro
on est bien là on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et en attend
vos points de vue on attend vos points
de vue sur la réécriture de l'article 24
le fameux article 24 de la loi sur la
sécurité globale alors on attendra des
propositions d'isabelle saporta ce soir
bonsoir isabelle je vous conseille de
lire le dernier livre d'isabelle saporta
surtout surtout si vous détestez la
technocratie allez-y c'est le moment de
se défouler de se faire plaisir et de
trouver selon notre auteur dit bonne
raison de persévérer dans cette
détestation alors moi je n'ai pas
toujours été convaincu mais j'ai
toujours été séduit parce que c'est bien
c'est très bien écrit c'est scandaleux
d'avoir autant de talent avec verve
c'est drôle surtout quand cette mauvaise
foi et puis si vous aimez les
déclarations d'amour c'est aussi
l'occasion de se faire plaisir parce que
il avait une vibrante déclaration
d'amour que vous faites à la france a
son histoire à son peuple
rendez nous la france sept aux éditions
fayard je voulais promis on en a parlé
face à la mauricie mais en plus j'ai de
bonnes raisons parce que comme je disais
avant je les lui jusqu'à la fin comme
candide et joris ne disent pas les
livres femme bascule est c'est pas vrai
face à vous alexis brézet directeur
d'action du figaro bonjour alex ans
vincent
alors de quoi pourriez-vous bien
débattre outre de l'article 24 je fais
ralik si chère isabelle et bien
peut-être de la nécessité ou non de
remettre la réforme des retraites sur le
devant de la scène en haut de la pile
des dossiers prioritaires êtes vous
comme bruno le maire pour êtes vous
comme laurent berger contre eh bien eh
bien on attend vos points de vue mais
d'abord comment réécrire l'article 24 de
la loi sur la sécurité globale alors en
vain d'en débattre je vous soumets
d'avoir la question du jour sur le site
du figaro où il y a plus de 60000 vote
déjà avez vous une bonne image de la
police en regardant la réponse à la fin
de cette première partie concerne en
tout cas la réécriture de l'article 24
voici deux points de vue diamétralement
opposé d'abord l'écologiste eric piolle
et ensuite le républicain guillaume
pottier bon ok y'a rien à garder
finalement dans l'état d'esprit de cette
loi il a fait clairement une proposition
de loi qui est en dehors des clous
évidemment qu'il faut la retirer
moi je regrette que le président de la
république et sa majorité et sur les
questions de sécurité la main qui
tremble et la main qui tremble
donc pour le maintien isabelle est ce qu
on peut réécrire
c'est quand même les pieds nickelés sont
son sont aux manettes de la france mais
enfin je pardonnez moi mais moi je vais
vous dire je vois les pieds nickelés
sont aux manettes de la france il y
avait bien un très bon politologue que
vous interviewez en page 2 de filières
benjamin morel qui parlait qui
scandaient l'amateurisme de ce
gouvernement amateurisme parce que
d'abord effectivement richard ferrand le
patron l'assemblée nationale s'il avait
un doute ils auraient dû saisir le
conseil d'état amateurisme encore parce
que castex notre premier ministre afin
qu'il devait nous être l'homme du bon
sens manifestement ne connaît pas le la
vème république le bicamérisme ni le
processus législatif mme king qui nous
proposait un comité théodule absurde et
encore un matheux risme parce que
maintenant que l'amendement est voté
après pardonnez-moi mais l'amendement a
été voté
celanese roule aujourd'hui mais voilà
donc normalement c'est la navette
parlementaire et l'as minguettes au
sénat donc qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bal des tartuffes avec castaner qui fait
une conférence de presse en disant nous
allons de réécrire mais ils n'ont plus
la main pour le réécrire donc de toute
façon on est dans quelque chose qui n'a
aucun sens et par ailleurs si vraiment
il considérait que cet amendement que
moi je ne trouve pas bon moins que je
trouve détestable mais s'ils
considéraient qu'il n'était pas bon
pourquoi l'ont ils voter pourquoi l'ont
ils me ans en plein fouet et ça n'a
aucun sens
tout ça n'a aucun sens donc on peut pas
leur écrire on va y vont le réécrire
bien sûr mais enfin si vous voulez tout
ça n'est pas dans le respect de la vème
république
c'est ça qui me charles n'est pas la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale qui
peut leur écrire il va être écrite dé
facto comme tous les textes de loi sont
réglées par le sénat
l'article 5 prostitution quand un truc
est votée à l'assemblée et au sénat la
le sénat fait ce qu'il veut avec qui il
en fait des coupons fétis il apprend que
s'il veut il leur écrit le chant japy ça
repart à l'assemblée si l'urgence n'a
pas été claire et là encore ça l'a été
dans la limite ça devrait même pas rater
à l'assemblée façon on peut me faire
marche arrière et ça repart à
l'assemblée ça revient au sénat puis on
se met d'accord
à la fin si on n'est pas d'accord c'est
l'assemblée qui tranche donc à la fin
oui la majorité à l'assemblée pour
écrire un texte mais pas maintenant la
maintenance et au sénat est donc le
sénat dit attendez vous êtes gentil le
texte il est chez nous maintenant c'est
nous qui allons en faire ce que nous
souhaitons faire alors que maintenant on
va voir ce que le sénat peut avoir envie
d'en faire alors votre point de vue
justement qu'est ce que doit faire le
sénat sur sur la question est-ce qu'il
doit purement et simplement le retirer
comme
le suggère eric piolle kamerhe je pense
que si on veut sauver cette fois-ci
culte et de global qui dans l'ensemble
je pense est bonne il faut se
débarrasser de l'article 24 qui sert au
mieux à rien et au pire peut être je
dirais pas qu'il est détestable millet
aquila des points d'étape inquiétant
semble de liberté donc et franchement il
ne sert à rien il ya eu on a fait une
liste là de toutes les dispositions
juridiques qui permettent de répondre
aux objectifs que s'assigne ce fameux
article 24 donc je vais pas faire toute
la liste mais entre appels malveillants
menaces harcèlement atteinte à la vie
privée diffamation injure provocation
notamment pour les détenteurs de
l'autorité publique il ya déjà dix
disposition huit dispositions du code
pénal de loi qui permette ce qui
permettrait si on le voulait de
poursuivre les gens qui jettent en
pâture les policiers ou d'ailleurs de
simples citoyens parce qu'on n'a pas le
droit non plus de dénoncer son épicier
ou sur le concierge en le disant allez
la porte de chez lui cassé lui la figure
on n'a pas le droit non plus donc si on
voulait on pourrait la vérité c'est
qu'on ne le fait pas pour deux raisons
d'abord c'est souvent ces raisons de
manque de moyens puisque notamment pour
poursuivre sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux
il faudrait beaucoup plus d'enquêteurs
notamment dans la cellule pharos
beaucoup plus de magistrats pour
instruire donc il faudrait beaucoup plus
moyen il faudrait un peu plus de courage
politique et que le parquet décide de
temps en temps dire ça on ne laissera
pas passer
on le fait pas c'est pas parce qu'on
fera une fois de plus qu'on le fera
davantage avez passez tout ça c'est de
l'habillage c'est pour dire aux
policiers on est de votre côté mais bien
sûr qu'on est de leur côté
mais c'est pas avec des lois qui servent
à rien qu'on manifeste quand on est du
côté de la police alexis brézet appuyé
sur le vrai problème j'avais jean louis
debré l'autre jour qui expliquait tout
ça il dit ancien ministre ancien
président du conseil constitutionnel il
dit au fond aujourd'hui le processus
législatif et au fond c'est sous macro
mais ça aurait pu être aussi sous les
présidents précédents 1 est devenue une
espèce d'outillage de communication
c'est à dire qu'au fond nous avons acté
nous enfin les politiques contacter leur
impuissance 1
et vous avez raison au fond là ça
demande un travail de fond un travail de
fond d'ailleurs qui a esquissé darmanin
lors de son audition c'est à dire voilà
comment on fait pour former les
policiers pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
dérapage on a honte 15,9 et castaner
on réduit la formation des policiers
s'ils étaient sans doute une erreur
comment on fait pour essayer de
légiférer ils ont raté justement et
avaient essayé avec la loi vient sur les
réseaux sociaux toutes ces questions là
qui sont des questions de fond qui
demande beaucoup de travail mais le
travail voyez ça ne se voit pas on ne
peut pas communiquer dessus mais c'est
ça qu'il faudrait faire donc du coup
fait de la com avec des effets de de
menton sur cet amendement qui en plus
d'être détestable ne sert de rien et par
ailleurs je veux dire autre chose en
finalement en opposant de type de
journalisme
le journalisme au fond traditionnel et
celui de la rue il arrive en fait en
plus il arriverait quasiment a donné
raison aux complotistes c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui une partie de la population
n'a plus confiance en la presse à la
confiance dans ce journalisme de terrain
à tort ou à raison
et là on fait comme si au fond on les
disait eux donc je pense que si vous
laissez c'est totalement absurde
les avesnois pas être d'accord et
d'ailleurs c'est bien parce que je crois
qu'il ya une différence fondamentale
entre ce qu'on appelle le jeu
aujourd'hui professionnels des gens qui
vivent de ce métier je relis dans des
entreprises de presse répertorie comme
tel et cette nouvelle façon d'informer
qu'on appelle le journaliste citoyen les
lanceurs de la serre je ne prétends pas
que les journalistes professionnels soit
malin plus honnête plus dans le vrai
plus de travailleurs non je ne sais pas
ça le sujet le sujet c'est quoi on est
là dans une démarche juridique notamment
de recherche en responsabilité si demain
le figaro n'importe quel journal qui a
pignon sur rue et responsable
aujourd'hui le site flic machin
surveillant les flics ou même un site
très sympathique je sais mais écrit
quelque chose qui laisse des intérêts de
quelqu'un ou les intérêts de la société
on se retourne y a pas de patron il ya
pa directeurs de publication il n'y a
pas d'organisation donc on ne peut pas
mettre en cause la responsabilité
le principe de la liberté c'est la
responsabilité la presse à des as à
l'ombre de 2,2 de liberté de privilège
dit de juridiction c'est-à-dire qu'on
passe toujours devant la même chambre
qu'on peut pas comparaître de façon
immédiate que les charge de la preuve
il faut que ce soit la partie adverse
qui le fasse mais on a ça manque de
responsabilité et la preuve de
responsabilité c'est qu'aujourd'hui si
dans nos commentaires d'internautes en a
des dizaines de milliers tous les jours
c'est pas un seul de ces que ses
commentaires et raciste homophobe
injurieux appels à la haine
marc feuillée le directeur de la
publication peut être traînés devant les
tribunaux
du jour au lendemain e choc est pas le
cas pour facebook pour google pourtant
tous et pour tous ses citoyens
donc je dis c'est pas la même chose le
jour dix professionnels et des gens qui
sont dans le cadre de la liberté
d'expression qui est tout à fait
respectable qui doit être protégé mais
les têtes d'expression n'est pas
exactement ni tout à fait la même chose
qu'en liberté de la presse où il ya des
contraintes
il ya aussi des garanties alors je
préférerais qu'on les fasse rentrer dans
la liberté de la presse qui t'a les
professionnaliser et aller entre
guillemets vous voyez à faire en sorte
qu'il se structure et par ailleurs je
pense que c'est ce qui est en train de
faire vous parlez de la
responsabilisation des réseaux sociaux
c'est ce qu'on est en train d'essayer de
faire en tout cas tirer breton au niveau
européen
espérons diaries en disant au fond si
demain demain les réseaux sociaux seront
seront comment dire responsable et en
plus on regardera quel est le comment
dire le réseau passant c'est à dire
suivant combien de personnes pourront
regarder
ils seront d'autant plus responsable
donc ça c'est très important mais ça
voyez ça c'est du travail c'est du
travail qui se fait dans l'ombre et
c'est pas une une fois faux amendement
site entre guillemets citoyens qui pour
certains sont à la limite de l'islamo
gauchisme voire de l'islamisme pour
d'autres d'un extrémisme de gauche anti
flics répréhensible pénalement
vous n'aurez jamais détecté la culture
ce qui ne le veulent pas tout ça c'est
sous couvert d'anonymat pour président
qu'on ne puisse pas attraper des propos
qui sont sous le coup de la loi
mais six ans ou coup de la loi et qu'on
n'a pas de responsable il faut bien
trouver un autre moyen pour le poulet
pour pour qu'ils répondent de leurs
écrits sinon il va par là effectivement
dans ces cas là la responsabilisation
des réseaux sociaux et de ses tuyaux
qu'est ce que voulez que je vous dise
bac de toute façon c'est vrai vous avez
raison il faut une responsabilisation
par contre je pense que la victimisation
de ses journalistes mme hars alternatif
est une erreur parce que je pense
qu'effectivement on est dans une période
c'est une erreur oui puis c'est une
erreur parce que on est dans une période
ça ne vous a pas échappé qui est très
angoissante
on voit bien que les français sont de
plus en plus tentés par le complotisme
et en plus on peut même pas leur donner
entièrement tort se dire on leur a menti
on leur a menti dans les yeux on leur a
dit que le mas comme servait de rien on
n'a pas arrêté de faire des erreurs de
communication inouïe donc si vous voulez
je pense que victimiser ce qu'ils voient
à tort ou à raison comme des sauveurs ou
comme les vrais journalistes
ça n'est pas faire avancer le débat
public dans le bon sens christophe
demande les réseaux sociaux responsables
vous y croyez vraiment ah mais moi j'en
avais dit quoi c'est à dire que soit
breton réussi son coup de force
vis-à-vis des gaffes armes et on
retrouve au fond un petit peu de
souveraineté au niveau européen soit
c'est pas le cas et je peux vous dire
qu'on se prépare pas des lendemains qui
chantent un alexis vous parliez d'une
autre d'une autre loi vous faisiez
brièvement allusion l'hôte loi qui en
discussion à partir de la semaine
prochaine qui est la loi censée lutter
contre le séparatisme je donne pas de
nom ce que j'arrive pas n'a toujours pas
à savoir quel sera le nom qui sera sera
de la séparatiste puis la laïcité puis
l'ol doivent en principe prêt principes
républicains ont un truc elle quelque
chose comme ça qui crée un délit de mise
en danger de la vie d'autrui par
diffusion d'informations relatives à la
vie privée ou professionnelle
donc si on est sur un site interne
applique ça dont il s'agit des
informations relatifs avec l'adresse et
le groupe quelqu'un qui sait pas
forcément un policier qui peut être moi
même alors au public pas forcément vie
d'autres personnes
d'aucuns agent public ça peut être un
fictivement un professeur a fait cet
effet au lendemain de la sphère de cette
bâtisse mais ça papa obligé
donc on vient y aurait un délit que
d'autres il faut prendre contre les
journalistes professionnels dans le
cadre de lois 10 880 les autres dans le
cadre d'une procédure de comparution
immédiate avec des règles de droit qui
sont pas exactement les mêmes et dans
les deux caches tout le monde a serait
responsable de ça oui mais du coup on se
demande bien pourquoi ils sont à lire a
ajouté la maman de enfin envoyer
l'article 24 lits parce que vous
attribuez le pataquès actuel autour de
cet article m'a décrit à la bureaucratie
la technocratie
quand vous citez ferrand et les autres
j'ai pas l'impression
là enfin pardon vous vous souvenez quand
macron se féliciter en leur disant soyez
fiers d'être des amateurs
là on est à deux ans de la prochaine
présidentielle il serait temps que ça
devienne des professionnels mais là je
pense que c'est surtout darmanin qui a
voulu effectivement non pardon je vous
aime et on tout le monde dise ce faux de
dormir évidemment il est très
responsable et puis la fourmi énormément
de l'huile sur le feu en expliquant
qu'on allait flouter les visages alors
que c'est même pas dans la loi en
expliquant qu'il fallait que j'en aie
aie se référant c'est la préfecture
alors que c'est nul ça ne repose t il en
a rajouté mais il faut se dire que le 15
octobre c'est emmanuel macron qui reçoit
à l'elysée les syndicats ce police avait
raison au lendemain d'une certain nombre
d'événements de violences infligées aux
policiers il y avait savigny-sur-orge
rassemble deux villes où savez c'était
les tirs de mortiers aura et donc ils me
retirent reçoit tous les syndicats y le
redis avec l'harmonie et l'audio on
comprend on est de votre côté
on va faire une loi dans cette loi il ya
un certain nombre de dispositions parmi
lesquels le fait qu'on n'aura pas le
droit de diffuser des images manif est
manifestement destiné à vous nuire
donc c'est macron qui le dit donc il
faut pas c'est pas il ne l'a pas
découvert ça et là vous avez
parfaitement raison c'est que cette
espèce de tartufferie totale là où
maintenant on a on sait que macron était
très en colère la colère blanche la
colère noire la colère verte dont on est
d'accord tout ça s'éteint c'est un jeu
quoi c'est une c'est us et voilà on est
deux on est d'en douter un effort énorme
et on est dans du théâtre mais le vrai
problème c'est que plus personne n'y
croit
pourquoi il ya eu 60% d'abstention
municipal pourquoi là moi je vois en
train nous dire on va faire le vote par
correspondance mais comme le disait très
justement jean louis debré le problème
c'est l'envié
le désir de politique là il ya un moment
on a quand même vraiment l'impression
qu'ils nous prennent pour des canards
sauvages en permanence donc si vous
voulez le désir n'est plus là et
effectivement il ya un milliard de
choses à faire pour la police j'ai la
chance en tant qu'éditrice de publier
beaucoup de policiers
je vais vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire la formation leur donnait
effectivement des voitures qui est pas
250 mille kilomètres au compteur
voilà il y avait des choses à faire et
les caméras jusqu'aux mathis et le port
des caméras pression trouve ça très bien
et le seul problème qu'on ait eue c'est
que là encore on a voulu radiner on leur
a trouvé des caméras made in china qui
n'avait aucune batterie donc les mecs
ils ont leurs caméras et les aidants
aidés de la déclencher bip c'est fini au
bout de cinq minutes
m enfin votre part en plus acheter non
qu'ils achètent déjà leurs menottes dans
machin truc pas tout ça n'a aucun sens
donc ça c'est très bien puisque au moins
ils auront des images aussi eu aussi
pour se défendre c'est bien pour tout le
monde y vient pour tous ses biens pour
les éventuelles victimes d'éventuels
brutalité policière
et c'est bien pour les policiers qui eux
mêmes sont victimes de brutalité de deux
voyous tous les jours et par milliers et
donc le fait de pouvoir le montrer en
disant regardez vous avez diffusé des
images où je donne un coup sur la tête
mais regardez tout ce qu'ils avaient
avant
voilà ce qui m'a fait voler ce qui m'a
fait ou est ce que vous voyez pas ce
qu'on va toujours le même bout donc ça
permet de 2 après faudra voir comment on
utilise ces images qui les diffusent
dans quel comme on les encadre
mais mais bien sûr je pense que c'est
bien pour tout le monde les policiers le
disent ils disent tous nous on est
preneur il attend et vous répondait
ainsi à pierre selon moi les policiers
devraient film est systématiquement ne
rien faire qui leur soit interdite c'est
pourtant aussi simple que cela mais
c'est des questions parfois sont
également des questions de moyens des
questions budgétaires parce que vous
utilisez bonne note après on l'a on a
bien vu le dérapage qui plus qu'un
dérapage qui s'est passé avec ce
producteur
mais si vous voulez de toute façon
aujourd'hui on a on met sur le terrain
des jeunes qui sont pas formés et on met
sur le terrain des jeunes qui sont pas
formés notamment à paris en région
parisienne donc c'est à dire là où c'est
le plus difficile donc ça ça
effectivement il faut s'y atteler
j'espère qu'ils vont s'y atteler nathan
nous dit l'article 24 et ridicule
comment voulez vous empêcher quelqu'un
de filmer dans une manifestation qui ne
prétend pas ce qu'il ne prétend pas un
peu haché de fimela prétend empêcher de
diffuser mais évidemment la tentation
serait grande s'il avait été votée pour
le policier de dire t'as pas
relisez donc tu filmes pas ce qui est
déjà le cas désolé alors quel droit
allez pour contribuer au débat zoo ce
qui nous dit les violences commises par
la police sont insupportables
institutions de rien trop puissante avec
avec de puissants syndicats le tout
sécuritaire n'est pas une solution trop
puissante avec de puissants syndicats
s'opposent et donc moi je pense qu'elle
n'a jamais été aussi fait mais c'est
pour ça qu'il ya ces dérives
je pense que c'est le problème si vous
voulez et là on a on s'est retrouvé avec
un sarkozy qui a diminué les de 10000
les troupes sur le terrain on à
cazeneuve qui pour essayer au lendemain
des attentats de faire en sorte de
mettre plus de policiers sur le terrain
a raccourci la fin la formation ça a été
aussi entériné après par castaner et on
se retrouve dans devant une institution
moi je pense qu'il n'a jamais été aussi
affaiblie qui n'a jamais autant manquer
de moyens qui n'a jamais été aussi
méprisé et je pense que c'est ça qui
fait ça triste et le problème de ces
fantassins que vous mettez partout c'est
le plus difficile qu'ils ne se sentent
déjà pas respectées qui se sentent des
classes et je pense que c'est sain
métaireau regardez ces deux images qui
se font face et qu'on a vu
successivement les images de ces
brutalités policières insupportable sous
réserve bien sûr des résultats de
l'enquète mafa qui paraissent assez
nette est de l'autre côté ces brutalités
des black blocks sur ces malheureux
policier qui se sont fait rouer de coups
lâchait d'ailleurs leur candidat alors
on comprend rien est-ce qu'ils sont trop
dures où est-ce qu'ils sont débordés
mais ils sont les deux à la fois sur la
brutalité est toujours le sanction d'une
faiblesse et le revers là vers d'une
même médaille
quand on est faible la vraie autorité
c'est pas la brutalité
quand on est fort on n'a pas besoin
d'être brutal quand on est faible de
temps en temps on track où tous les
parents ou parents connaît tous avec les
enfants qu'on n'aurait pas effet robin
mais c'est la brutalité est le reflet la
traduction d'une faiblesse donc on a ce
paradoxe d'avoir une police qui parfois
rarement faut quand même le dire mais
parfois est brutal et le plus souvent
malheureusement est débordé c'est un peu
spécialement la formation estime nicole
le problème ce niveau de recrutement
ça va avec un plein de choses c'est
aussi la sanction pénale qui vient pas
quand quand ils arrêtent d enfin vous la
raconter c'est un milliard de fois mais
quand il a déjà en une fois deux fois
trois fois quatre fois cinq fois et que
c'est ces gens se retrouvent dehors le
lendemain avec un rappel à la loi à 65
rappel à la loi
ils ont tendance ce qui est condamnable
ce qui n'est pas dit
alors taper sur la tête en disant moi ça
ils l'auront c'est ça aussi la brutalité
policière c'est on va se faire justice
nous mêmes parce qu'on sait que la
justice se fera pas mais là où nicolas
parfaitement raison c'est comment enfin
pour recruter il faut encore rendre ces
métiers attrayant pardon mais est ce que
vous avez envie vous d'être policier vue
1 combien ils sont rémunérés vu qu'ils
risquent leur vie chaque jour je veux
dire et dans quelles conditions et
travaille enfin vous avez vous êtes déjà
rentré dans un commissariat où vous
voyez les loue les locaux l'épreuve
aujourd'hui tous les services publics
français tous les tentations de la
république qu'il soit propre qu'il soit
fait qu'ils soient hospitalier a
vraiment faut avoir le moral c'est bien
au toit moyenne ça pour vivre dans des
cités où ils sont entourés des gens qui
passent leur temps à quoi va courir
après dans la journée avec eux mêmes
leurs femmes leurs enfants en danger
nous emmerder à l'école et ses faubourgs
vouloir vous êtes un peu presque 65000
avoir déjà répondu à notre question avez
vous une bonne image de la police et
pour l'instant c'est l'art je vous
répondais largement oui à plus de 78% et
vous continuez à voter à répond sur le
site du figaro l'autre question qu'on me
pose
elle est sur twitter hashtag point de
vue c'est la réforme des retraites
doit-elle doit-elle redevenir une
priorité on pose la question après avoir
lu cette déclaration de bruno le maire
l'état remboursera sa dette grâce au
retour de la croissance
ensuite par la maîtrise de nos dépenses
et enfin par des réformes structurelles
comme la réforme des retraites qui doit
être la priorité absolue alors est ce
que c'est votre avis avant de
prendre connaissance et de leur donner
je vous propose d'écouter celui du
ministre des relations avec le parlement
marc fesneau et du numéro un de la cfdt
laurent berger pas la priorité absolue
du gouvernement c'est de régler la crise
sanitaire on a des sujets vaccinaux qui
vont venir devant nous on a une crise
économique et sociale c'est de faire en
sorte que les gens puissent sortir de la
précarité dans laquelle ils sont en
train de s'enfoncer du fait de cette
crise sanitaire et social c'est ça la
priorité c'est pas autre chose à mon
avis
pour travailler sur le fond d'un système
universel de retraite on peut continuer
à y réfléchir
y a pas de sujet là dessus pour nous il
n'y a pas de problème mais si comme
c'était plutôt l'orientation prise par
monsieur le maire c'est une question de
réforme financière des retraites
la réponse est non pour la sellette été
clairement j'ai dit si d'ici la
présidentielle soyons clairs il met
impossibilité sauf à vouloir une
explosion sociale
mais raisonnable si de remettre sujet
des retraites
moi je dirais exactement le contraire de
berger c'est à dire que si le sujet
c'est de refaire la fameuse réforme
systémique dont on nous a rebattu les
oreilles pendant des mois donc auquel
personne n'a rien compris on a seulement
compliqué de faire un site et un point
magnifique qui était une sorte de
chefs-d'oeuvre technocratique pour
plaire aux inspecteurs en finance ou en
alsace justement automatique du point
mais justement du point que à la hausse
parce qu'un ajustement à la baisse
n'était pas envisageable
il faut m'expliquer ce que c'est qu'un
système de prix ou le prix ne peut pas
baisser ça ne sert absolument à rien
puisque le plus grand la grand projet d'
emmanuel macron c'est de faire une
réforme qui ne feraient pas faire
d'économie jeudi si c'est pour ça c'est
pas la peine de s'embêter
c'est vraiment pas le sujet le faisons
en a mille autres choses à faire que
faire le truc sublime qui ne devra pas
faire d'économies sur la question des
économies dois dire que il ya quelque
chose de ce qui est vrai dans ce que dit
bruno le maire sait qu'on est en train
de dépenser des milliards et des
milliards et des milliards des murs
c'est très bien c'est très utile à la
fin défaillants comme plus de chômeurs à
la fin des fire gamme aussi plus de
retraités puisqu'il est comme toute
série de plans de licenciements
où sont les vieux qui ont fait partir
donc s'il ya moins de gens qui cotisent
pascal plus de chômeurs et plus de
retraités déjà notre système est en
déséquilibre structurel
parce que la vérité tout le monde le
sait ce qu ont trahis pas ya passé
d'actifs pour le nombre de retraités
ça va dégrader le rapport entre le
nombre d'actifs et nombre de retraités
donc il ya quand même bien un moment où
il va falloir remonter le nombre
d'actifs
donc soit on a un miracle la croissance
va revenir tout seul ce qui me paraît
peu probable soit il faudra faire ce
qu'on fait tous les pays autour de nous
c'est de faire travailler les gens un
peu plus longtemps alors c'est pas
agréable pour autant ce n'est pas une
réforme régressive de finhan
financièrement ça n'est pas fermée on
nous dit ça va ça va étouffer la
croissance non de faire travailler des
gens pour longtemps
c'est désagréable pour ceux qui n'ont
pas envie de travailler ça je le conçois
mais ça ne change absolument rien à
agnetz l'investissement ni à la
consommation n'y a rien donc je vous dit
c'est pas travailler plus pour gagner
moins
moins mais ce travail plus longtemps
pour continuer à gagner ce qu'on gagne
way isabelle alors déjà si on veut avoir
une idée un peu de votre livre de ce
qu'on raconte dans votre livre est bien
on se reporte à ce qu'il ya de dire à
bixi sur la réforme des retraites et sur
l'est sur les chênes verts
technocratique visant décrivez comme
cela pendant dix ans 2
voix et les 18 mois soit dix ans de
concertation qui avait précédé cette
réforme
c'était un chef-d'oeuvre c'est à dire
que delevoye pendant 18 mois a fait une
concertation et on arrive au moment où
il présente la réforme personne n'était
capable de nous dire de combien serait
le point qui le fixerait comment ça
allait se passer
c'était ahurissant je veux dire
rappelez-vous les manifestations
monstres qu'on a eu en france
je dirais les petits commerces et les
restaurateurs était à genoux un parce
que on avait enchaîné les manifestations
des gilet jaune puis les manifestations
des retraites
moi je vais vous dire plusieurs choses
hein je pense que comme berger c'est pas
le moment
c'est à dire que je pense que ce pays
est déjà infiniment fracturée je pense
que les petits commerçants les
restaurateurs si rouvre un jour les
pauvres restaurateurs ce que j'espère de
tout coeur le plus vite possible
n'auront pas besoin de ça parce que ça
ne se passera pas bien parce que ce sera
fait comme d'habitude de façon
complètement ahurissant c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien que effectivement bruno
le maire veut une réforme paramétrique
pour effectivement faire des économies
on voit bien qu'une partie la macro ni
dont la ministre du travail veut elle
une réforme systémique pour plus
d'égalité et je pense que c'est une
réforme qu'il faudra faire sans doute un
moment donné puisque effectivement il ya
une inégalité totale entre les retraités
en france
maintenant pour tout vous dire la route
là les choses telles qu'elles sont
faites aujourd'hui en france sont aussi
qu' on se retrouve avec des seniors 1
qui ne sont plus dans le monde du
travail
quand on se retrouve avec la moitié des
des gens qui sont en âge de partir à la
retraite qui sont soit déjà au chômage
soit en arrêt maladie soit dans les
minima sociaux
donc de toute façon et ce serait ça qui
serait bien qu'ils fassent plutôt que de
faire semblant de faire une retraite
qu'ils à une réforme qui n'arriveront
pas à faire passer
déjà qu'ils s'attèlent à faire à
réintégrer seniors dans le monde du
travail
1 si on veut faire travailler les gens
plus longtemps déjà qu'on lui laisse
question vivre pardon mais il ya système
très simple pour faire très vite rallye
jean plus autant aujourd'hui jeudi par
65 qu'est ce que font les entreprises
elles commencent à faire des plans pour
les jeux entre 60 et 62 vous mettez
l'aja 67 les elles feront des plans pour
les gens entre 64 et 66 c'est comme ça
c'est c'est
donc si on veut faire en sorte que les
seniors travaillent plus longtemps il
faut décaler d'un petit cran le départ
d'agen retraite dans toutes les
entreprises c'est comme ça que ça se
passe
donc bon je reconnais que est ce que
c'est le moment c'est pas agréable c'est
difficile vous parliez des inégalités la
principale d'égalité aujourd'hui c'est
pas entre les commerçants et les
salariés du privé et c'est à dire c'est
pas là c'est pas les commerçants qui
serait visée pas une fois la principale
égalité et inégalités c'est c'est ce
régime dont bénéficient les
fonctionnaires qui ont été absolument et
tant mieux pour eux épargnés par la
crise de kovy donc ya pas de chômage n'y
a pas de nos rues n'ont rien eu à équipe
arrière bénéficient d'une d'un système
de retraite très ou assez privilégiés le
vrai problème de la fonction publique un
débat qu'il faudra sans doute avoir un
moment donné mais le vrai problème à la
fonction publique
vous prenez les professeurs connaît les
policiers prenaient tous ces gens le
contraint c'est vous êtes mal payé toute
votre vie mais je vous dis pas le
contraire mais vous avez la stabilité de
l'emploi vous allez ma virale pardonnez
moi cette trivialité et vous avez 7 me
trompe c'est le contrat 1 donc dans ces
cas là il faut revoir tous les bouts du
contrat c'est à dire de dire au fond à
écouter peut-être que vous pouvez vous
faire perdre votre emploi vous pouvez
aussi peu progressé beaucoup plus
rapidement moi je me rappelle très bien
que quand j'étais jeune chercheuse au
début de ma carrière on se retrouvait
avec moi les trois quarts de mes amis
qui était chercheur en scientifique
partait aux états unis ou ailleurs parce
que l'avancement se faisait beaucoup
plus vite
alors que nous c'est toujours un
ancienneté on se retrouve dans des
danses effectivement dans des systèmes
qui sont sclérosant et sa part dont il
va pas le faire en une deux trois ça
c'est des choses qu'il faut mettre sur
la table et travaillé longuement ce que
sinon vous allez voir ils vont nous
faire comme le l'article 24 ans et sont
capables de nous faire aussi mr 2 pour
la réforme ce qui était dans les tuyaux
pour la réforme des retraites c'est
exactement le contraire de ce qu'on est
en train de dire ça te diront 10 rebonds
on touche pas aux fonctionnaires on a
compris vol paris sont pas contents et
donc on ne touche à rien et ça va être
les salariés du privé et les
indépendants qui vont payer ça serait
pire que tout si c'est pour ça il faut
absolument rien faire est ce que c'est
au fond on va faire comme ça pour tout
le monde sauf pour machin pour trucs
pour bidule machin on avait bien
commencé a commencé et ils ont commencé
à faire cinquante mille exception
moi je vais vous dire un truc je pense
qu'il faut relancer la machine
économique
je pense qu'il faut qu'on se remette
tous à travailler et en vrai je ne crois
pas que mâcon soit assez fort là dessus
on est d'accord on saura toucher qu'à
faire on économisera plus rien et donc
fait donc on peut pas il donc ils vont
pas toucher les bruno le maire est une
voie qui clem dans le nord
oui mais dans ce rôle et puis france il
prend date pour la suite lui le radier
les choses et puis on les aura pas fait
sous entendu ce gouvernement ce premier
ministre se présente un public pas très
courageux de la paf et moi bruno le
maire je l'aurais fait il sait très bien
qu'on le fera pas en fera plus rien mais
là où je jouais juste après un pas de
géant c'est que l'allongement du temps
de travail n'est pas une réforme
régressive du point de vue de la
croissance
ça ne ça ne diminue ni l'investissement
ni la consommation simplement ça oblige
des gens qui n'ont pas forcément envie à
travailler un peu plus longtemps
ça permet aussi à des gens qui serait
bien qu'on en garde et leur boulot de
regarder c'est une réforme cette réforme
est une priorité du dit christophe mais
elle est impossible dans ce contexte
social et sanitaire
est-ce que c'est pas justement le résume
on est tous d'accord et je pardon
j'ajouterai quelque chose de revenir un
sujet au fond si on l'avait compris
qu'il ferait plus rien en économie ce
qu'on pouvait espérer c'est qu'il ferait
quelque chose sur la sécurité
l'immigration le régalien hélas
malheureusement ce que je crains après
cet épisode absolument navrant que l'on
vient d'assister avec l'article 24 et
compagnie c'est qu' il soit aussi bloqué
là dessus maintenant parce qu'ils vont
avoir le plus grand mal à faire quoi que
ce soit et là et la loi séparatisme on
va voir mais ça va être très difficile
ce les conséquences de ce pataquès c'est
potentiellement la fin de ceux de cette
évolution vers plus de réalisme en
matière régaliennes que nous nous
appuyons nos voeux schéma contre le
gouvernement a déjà échoué à imposer une
réforme être nous dit nathan la gestion
déplorable but du coc vide
selon lui à plis fier le problème de la
place des anciens dans notre société
micheline estiment à l'inversé que c'est
loin d'être une priorité il faut une
revalorisation des retraités mais le
système de santé prioritaires il faut
augmenter les effectifs des hôpitaux
ça sera un autre débat on en parlera une
autre fois nicolas nous dit il faut
carrément annuler la réforme des
retraites car la france est suffisamment
fracturée nous voulons vivre dans le
calme
je crains nicolas sans vouloir m'avancer
ce soit un voeu pieux ont posé la
question la réforme des retraites
doit-elle redevenir la priorité du
gouvernement c'était la question que
vous posez sur le twitter vie blanc vous
n'êtes pas trop chaud sur 7 sur cette
perspective vis-à-vis de cette
perspective merci beaucoup de nous avoir
suivi donc demain dans l'enfant dans les
prochaines heures sur le figaro dans le
figaro on revient sur l'article 24
la fin du feuilleton est ce qu'on va
passer par l'article 25 de la loi c'est
partisme non mais alors comment va-t-on
faire rien voilà à lire dans les
prochaines heures dans le figaro on vous
met également dans le chatt j'aime
énormément dans le chatt également la
vérification dont parlait alexis sur
est-il juridiquement at-on juridiquement
besoin de l'article 24 c'est assez
exhaustif
vous allez voir et puis rendez nous la
france sept aux éditions fayard et
d'isabelle saporta qui veut dire vous
êtes plus journalistes vous êtes et
éditrice et vous allez peut-être a été
engagé en politique
également on l'a pas dit on la rappelle
aux côtés des écologistes et yannick
jadot
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis à
très vite sur le site du figaro et sur
fion life